I recently looked up the number of women in Congress. Fewer than one in five legislators are women. At Fortune 500 companies fewer than one in twenty CEOs are women. And look at all the presidents of the United States through Barack Obama. Now, I know there was a long time when women couldn't be president, but if men and women had an equal shot at the White House, the odds of having 44 presidents in a row all be men, about 1 in 18 trillion. What explains the dirt of women in top leadership positions? Is it bias, a lack of role models, the old boys' club? Sure, but it goes deeper than that. Women are trapped in a catch-22, a paradox so deeply embedded in our culture that there are a few means of escape.
我最近查阅了国会中女性的人数。议员中女性还不到五分之一。在财富 500 强企业中，女性首席执行官连二十分之一都不到。再看看奥巴马之前的所有美国总统。现在，我知道过去很长一段时间女性都无法担任总统，但如果男女入主白宫的机会均等，连续 44 任总统全都是男性的概率大约是 18 万亿分之一。是什么解释了顶尖领导岗位中女性的匮乏？是因为偏见、缺乏榜样，还是老派男俱乐部？当然有，但事情远比这更深远。女性陷入了一种“第22条军规”式的困境，这种悖论深深植根于我们的文化中，以至于几乎找不到逃脱的方法。
And so it is really that very, very fine line between being a shrew on the one hand and a puppet on the other that any woman in public life has to walk. The puppet, the shrew, and the double-bind facing women who want to lead. This week on Hidden Brain. A few years ago, one of our listeners decided to switch careers. So, my name is Deborah Metta and I am a second year marketing student in an MBA program. Deborah had been a successful teacher, but the business world appealed to her. She thought she would be a good fit, so did the program to which she applied.
因此，每一个涉足公众生活的女性都必须走好这条非常非常微妙的钢丝：一面是泼妇，另一面是提线木偶。提线木偶、泼妇，以及想要领导地位的女性所面临的双重约束。本周的《隐藏的大脑》(Hidden Brain)。几年前，我们的听众之一决定转换职业。所以，我叫黛博拉·梅塔 (Deborah Metta)，我是 MBA 项目的一名二年级市场营销专业学生。黛博拉曾是一名成功的老师，但商业世界对她很有吸引力。她觉得自己很适合，她申请的项目也是这么认为的。
She was awarded a full scholarship. Soon, she was sharing the good news with an old friend. We met for coffee one day and she is very nice. I'm still really good friends with her, but she said to me, I really can't see you in business. I think you're, you know, too sweet for the business world. It was the beginning of a series of comments that undermined her belief that she could be
她获得了一笔全额奖学金。很快，她就把这个好消息分享给了一位老朋友。我们有一天见面喝咖啡，她人非常好。我和她仍然是非常好的朋友，但她对我说，我真的无法想象你进入商界。我觉得你，你知道的，对商界来说太温柔了。这是一系列言论的开端，这些言论削弱了她对自己能够成为
a leader or a manager. Later that year, Deborah's voice was the problem, specifically her habit of ending sentences on a higher pitch. A professor during a class mentioned that I do that, that I raised my, you know, pitch at the end of a sentence. The implication was that Deborah sounded like a lightweight, not manage a material. Deborah said she wasn't prepared for the offhand remarks. I mean it really was leading me to lose confidence, criticism of my voice, and then you know
领导者或经理的信念。那年晚些时候，黛博拉的声音成了问题，特别是她习惯在句子结尾时提高语调。课堂上一位教授提到我这样做，也就是我在句子末尾提高了，你知道的，语调。这其中的暗示是黛博拉听起来像个无足轻重的人，不是块当经理的料。黛博拉说她对这些随意的评论毫无准备。我的意思是，这真的导致我失去了信心，对我声音的批评，然后你知道的
everyone, not everyone, but several people telling me I'm too sweet for business. I think it really affected me. This is one side of the Catch 22. Women like Deborah are seen as not tough enough to be leaders. Another listener, Tully Winson, made a different set of choices. As a manager at a construction company, a female leader in a man's world, she decided to be strategic. From the way she dresses, I've definitely chosen to go a more masculine path, wearing Oxford shoes and button-downs, a straight pulled-back hair and pants. To the way she greets clients. You just, you know, just go in there and grab that hand and squeeze it because you have muscles too. I think that tends to help
每个人，也不是每个人，但有几个人告诉我，我太温柔了，不适合经商。我觉得这真的对我有影响。这是“第22条军规”的一面。像黛博拉这样的女性被认为不够坚强，无法成为领导者。另一位听众图利·温森 (Tully Winson) 做出了不同的选择。作为一家建筑公司的经理，一个男人世界里的女性领导者，她决定采取策略。从她的着装来看，我绝对选择了一条更男性化的道路，穿着牛津鞋和衬衫、梳着笔直向后的头发和裤子。到她迎接客户的方式。你只需，你知道的，走过去抓住那只手然后用力握紧，因为你也有肌肉。我认为这往往有助于
them go, oh wow, this is not just a lady. Tully doesn't want to appear soft or overly feminine because she knows that would be seen as weakness. But appearing tough turns out to create its own set of problems. It's definitely a double-edged sword because if I'm outspoken, all of a sudden, the men in the office will joke about,
他们觉得，哦哇，这不仅仅是一位女士。图利不想显得柔弱或过于女性化，因为她知道这会被视为软弱。但显得强硬结果却带来了一系列新的问题。这绝对是一把双刃剑，因为如果我直言不讳，办公室里的男人们突然就会开玩笑说，
oh, whoa, whoa, watch out for Tuley, watch out, she's dangerous that one. Dangerous, not driven, not strong, dangerous. We tell you their stories because together, Tuley and Debra's experiences reveal a powerful phenomenon that plays out when women strive to become leaders. The problem doesn't end with getting to the corner office, women confront the same issues when it comes to exercising power. It's a double-bind. Social psychologist Alice Eglie says the double-bind comes about because of a series of unconscious interlocking stereotypes we have about men, women, and the nature of leadership. The female gender role is based on the stereotype that women are nice and compassionate, but it's also expected.
哦，哇，哇，小心图利，小心点，那个女人很危险。危险，不是有干劲，不是坚强，而是危险。我们给你们讲他们的故事，因为图利和黛博拉的经历共同揭示了一个强有力的现象：当女性努力成为领导者时，这个现象就会上演。问题并没有随着进入高管办公室而结束，女性在行使权力时也会面临同样的问题。这是一个双重约束。社会心理学家爱丽丝·埃格利 (Alice Eagly) 表示，双重约束的出现是因为我们对男性、女性以及领导力本质有一系列无意识的交织刻板印象。女性的性别角色基于这样一种刻板印象：女性是善良和富有同情心的，这也是人们所期望的。
So people expect women to be kind of diced friendly. And smile. Now, Saisalis, consider a cultural stereotype about leaders. In a leadership role, what is expected to take charge? And sometimes, at least least to demonstrate toughness, make tough decisions, be very assertive in bringing an organization forward, sometimes fire people for cause, et cetera. So what's a woman to do? Be nice and kind and friendly
因此，人们期望女性表现得有点亲切友好。并且面带微笑。爱丽丝说，现在，考虑一下关于领导者的文化刻板印象。在领导岗位上，人们期望采取主导地位吗？有时，至少要表现出坚强，做出艰难的决定，在推动组织前进时非常果断，有时因故解雇员工，等等。那么女性该怎么做呢？表现得亲切、善良和友好
as our gender stereotypes about women require, or be tough and decisive as our stereotypes about leadership demand. To be one is to be seen as nice, but weak. To be the other is to be seen as competent, but unlikeable. The double bind exists for women like Tuley and Debra in the business world, but it also exists in public life, even for women with enormous power and experience. We talk to two women elected to high office, one is a Democrat, the other is a Republican.
正如我们对女性的性别刻板印象所要求的那样，或者表现得坚强和果断，正如我们对领导力的刻板印象所要求的那样。成为其中一种，就会被视为友好但软弱。成为另一种，就会被视为有能力但不可爱。对于像图利和黛博拉这样在商界打拼的女性来说，这种双重约束存在着，但在公众生活中它同样存在，甚至对于那些拥有巨大权力和经验的女性来说也是如此。我们采访了两位当选高级职务的女性，一位是民主党人，另一位是共和党人。
Their stories have many similarities. By the way, you may notice we refer to our guests by their first names, their agenda biases in the way the media use names. Journalists regularly refer to women by their first names, the way the media use names. Journalists regularly refer to women by their first names and men by their last names. On this podcast, in the interest of being conversational, we use first names for all guests. When Carol Mosley-Bron was elected to the US Senate, she achieved a powerful first. She was the first female African-American senator.
她们的故事有很多相似之处。顺便说一句，你可能会注意到我们用名字来称呼我们的嘉宾，媒体在使用名字时存在性别偏见。记者经常用女性的名字来称呼女性，媒体在使用名字时存在性别偏见。记者经常用女性的名字来称呼女性，而用男性的姓氏来称呼男性。在这个播客中，为了保持对话的自然，我们对所有嘉宾都使用名字。当卡罗尔·莫斯利-布劳恩 (Carol Moseley-Braun) 当选美国参议员时，她创造了一个强有力的第一。她是第一位非洲裔女性参议员。
Carol says growing up, her parents shielded her from finding out how bias might limit her choices. My parents had never given me a notion that I was limited anyway by my race or my gender. And that, you know, I could just do whatever it was that I thought I wanted to do and could do. But when she got into politics, Carol realized that race and gender did matter. Of the two, she thought that racism would be the bigger barrier. And I have to tell you that I think in some regards, the gender biases are more profound and more central to our culture than even the racial ones. And that, for me, was the surprise.
卡罗尔说，在成长过程中，她的父母保护她免于发现偏见如何限制她的选择。我的父母从来没有向我灌输过我以任何方式受到种族或性别限制的概念。而且你知道的，我只要做我觉得我想做而且能做的事情就行了。但当她进入政界后，卡罗尔意识到种族和性别确实很重要。在这两者中，她曾认为种族主义会是更大的障碍。我必须告诉你们，我认为在某些方面，性别偏见比种族偏见更深刻、更核心地植根于我们的文化中。对我来说，这才是惊喜。
I was expecting some pushback based on race and or gender. What I wasn't expecting was that the gender pushback would be as pronounced as it was, even more so than the racial ones. But shortly after Carol won her race, she says she confronted a second trap, the other side of the double bind. One time, she made an impassioned plea on the floor of the Senate, but she felt her colleagues were just tuning her out.
我曾预料到会遇到基于种族或/和性别的阻力。我没有料到的是，性别阻力会如此明显，甚至比种族阻力还要大。但卡罗尔赢得竞选后不久，她说她遇到了第二个陷阱，也就是双重约束的另一面。有一次，她在参议院讲台上发表了慷慨激昂的呼吁，但她觉得她的同事们根本不理睬她。
She opened in this country and getting rid of that safety net is what this so-called welfare reform is all about. All they could hear was a stril black woman. Just because it hasn't worked, and I submit to you, Mr. President, that it had... I came home that night. I was so upset and demeaning to use the word that I thought,
她在国内发起行动，摆脱那个安全网就是这个所谓的福利改革的全部意义所在。他们听到的只是一个尖锐的黑人女性。仅仅因为它没有起作用，我向您陈述，总统先生，它曾……那天晚上我回到家。我太心烦意乱了，用那个词来形容简直是贬低，以至于我想，
OK, that's it, I can't take this anymore, I'm going to quit. She didn't quit. But Carol still vividly recalls how unfair it felt. And it wasn't just over how she was being treated, she saw her experience in the long light of history. In the 15th century, women who talked back, they would put weights on their tongue and make them walk around the square. That's a shrews punishment. The idea of being that
好吧，就这样，我再也受不了了，我要辞职。她没有辞职。但卡罗尔依然清晰地记得那种不公平的感觉。这不仅是因为她受到的对待，她把自己的经历放在了漫长历史的光芒下来看。在 15 世纪，顶嘴的女性会被在舌头上挂上砝码，并被迫在广场上走来走去。那是对泼妇的惩罚。其背后的想法是
that you're not supposed to have opinions about things outside of the home. And so that's a real danger for any woman in public life. So every stranger gets to comment on how they what they think about you and what they think about what you just said. And if you said too much, that becomes a danger. If you said too little, that's a danger also. And so it is really that very, very fine line between being a shrew on the one hand and a puppet on the other that any woman in public life has to walk.
你不应该对家庭以外的事情有看法。所以这对公众生活中的任何女性来说都是真正的危险。因此，每个陌生人都可以对他们关于你的想法以及他们对你刚刚所说的话的想法发表评论。如果你说得太多，那就成了一种危险。如果你说得太少，那也是一种危险。因此，每一个涉足公众生活的女性都必须走好这条非常非常微妙的钢丝：一面是泼妇，另一面是提线木偶。
After serving one term in the Senate, Carol lost re-election in 1998. There is a sense that a woman has to be gracious and civil and smart and smile. This is Connie Morella. Connie served for 16 years as a Republican Congresswoman from Maryland. But she's got to be strong also and indicate that she's going to persevere. Like Democrat Carol Mosley-Bron, Connie says at times she struggled to be heard. In a committee room when I wasn't chair of the committee, I would respond to a question or a comment on an issue. And I would say, well, thank you, Connie.
在参议院任职一届后，卡罗尔在 1998 年的连任竞选中落败。人们有一种感觉，女性必须优雅、温和、聪明且面带微笑。这是康妮·莫雷拉 (Connie Morella)。康妮作为来自马里兰州的共和党女国会议员服务了 16 年。但她也必须坚强，并表明她会坚持不懈。就像民主党人卡罗尔·莫斯利-布劳恩一样，康妮说有时她很难被人倾听。在委员会会议室里，当我不是委员会主席时，我会回答关于某个问题的问题或评论。我会说，嗯，谢谢你，康妮。
That's great. And then a little later, Representative Smith said the very same thing I did. And it was, oh, Congressman Smith, that was fabulous. Let the record show that you have accomplished that or whatever. And I think, gee, I just said that. Connie Morella, Cal Mosley-Bran, Tulio Winson, Debra Metta, all these women feel they've experienced bias. But here's the thing, how do we know scientifically that they're right?
那很好。然后过了一会儿，史密斯众议员说的话和我一模一样。然后大家就说，哦，史密斯议员，那太棒了。请记录在案，你已经完成了那个或诸如此类的事情。我想，天哪，我刚刚才说过。康妮·莫雷拉、卡罗尔·莫斯利-布劳恩、图利·温森、黛博拉·梅塔，所有这些女性都觉得她们经历过偏见。但问题是，我们如何从科学上证明她们是正确的呢？
Carol Mosley-Bran senate colleagues may have felt that perception of her was accurate. The newspaper cartoonist may have felt she really was easily manipulated. In fact, Carol herself, in her interview with us, listed numerous misstep sheet made as a campaigner and as a senator. How can we tell with scientific certainty where the Carol was the victim of bias? When we look at a woman leader who appears incompetent or shrill, how do we know if we are seeing reality or just seeing the world through the lens of our own unconscious biases? This is where laboratory experiments are essential. They allow us to see precisely what's happening.
卡罗尔·莫斯利-布劳恩的参议院同事可能觉得他们对她的看法是准确的。报纸漫画家可能觉得她确实很容易被操纵。事实上，卡罗尔本人在接受我们的采访时，列举了她在竞选和担任参议员期间犯下的无数失误。我们如何以科学的确定性来判断卡罗尔是否是偏见的受害者？当我们看到一个看起来不胜任或尖锐的女领导人时，我们怎么知道我们看到的是现实，还是仅仅通过我们自己无意识偏见的镜头来观察世界？这就是实验室实验至关重要的地方。它们让我们能够精确地看到发生了什么。
We keep everything identical. We expose people to the various, what we call, experimental conditions. And at the end of the day, if we find a difference, we can say that it has to be due to that thing that we were studying. And that's the nature of a controlled experiment. Stay with us. When we judge a person's character, we usually think our opinions are based on fact. What we forget is that the world that enters our brain has been filtered.
我们保持一切完全相同。我们让人们接触各种我们所谓的实验条件。到了最后，如果我们发现了差异，我们就可以说这必定是由我们正在研究的那件事引起的。这就是对照实验的本质。请继续收听。当我们判断一个人的品格时，我们通常认为我们的意见是基于事实的。我们忘记的是，进入我们大脑的世界已经被过滤了。
Figuring out what those filters are and how they distort our vision has long intrigued Madeline Hylman. She's a psychology professor at New York University who focuses on gender stereotypes and bias, particularly when it comes to leadership. What we have found consistently is that when we present women and men with exactly the same credentials, qualifications and backgrounds, for a job that is traditionally male, held
弄清楚这些filters（过滤器）是什么以及它们如何扭曲我们的视线，长期以来一直吸引着玛德琳·海尔曼 (Madeline Heilman)。她是纽约大学的心理学教授，专注于性别刻板印象和偏见，特别是在领导力方面。我们始终发现的是，当我们向人们展示完全相同的资历、资格和背景时，对于一个传统上由男性担任的职位来说，
by men in our culture, thought to require male attributes, we consistently find that the woman is seen as more incompetent than the man. The problem doesn't end there. Sometimes women really do show their competence and it's unavoidable and we can't, we can't deny it. And what happens then? Well the research that I've done has shown that when women are truly successful in areas where they're not expected to be, there's a very negative reaction, there's disapproval,
在我们文化中由男性担任，被认为需要男性特质，我们始终发现女性被认为比男性更无能。问题并未就此结束。有时女性确实表现出了她们的能力，这是不可避免的，我们无法，我们无法否认。那会发生什么呢？好吧，我做过的前期研究表明，当女性在不被期望的领域真正取得成功时，会出现非常负面的反应，会有不赞同，
and they are penalized, they're disliked, but they're also seen as really almost really awful depictions of what kinds of people they are, words like bitter and quarrelsome, selfish and deceitful and devious and manipulative and cold. These are words that are attributed to these women who are successful where they are not supposed to be, and I should put that in quotes. We have terms for these people, you know, ice queen and dragon lady and iron maiden and so on and so forth. I want to emphasize these aren't Madeline's opinions. They are the findings of her experiments.
她们会受到惩罚，不招人喜欢，但她们也被视为几乎是对她们是哪种人的极其糟糕的描绘，诸如苦涩和好争吵、自私和虚伪、狡猾和诡计多端以及冷酷之类的词。这些词被用来形容那些在不该成功的领域取得成功的女性，我应该给这个说法加上引号。我们对这样的人有专门的称呼，你知道的，冰雪女王、龙夫人、铁娘子等等。我想强调的是，这些不是玛德琳的个人观点。它们是她实验的结果。
In one study Madeline asked volunteers to evaluate a high-powered manager joining a company. Sometimes volunteers are told the manager is a man, other times they're told it's a woman. When the person was presented as a very high-power person who was very ambitious we found that the person was seen as much more unlikable when it was a woman than when it was a man. To be clear the high-powered male and female manager are described in identical terms down to the letter. The only thing different is that one is set to be a man, and the other is set to be a woman. Madeline has also looked at what happens
在一项研究中，玛德琳让志愿者评估一位加入公司的强势经理。有时志愿者被告知这位经理是男性，其他时候被告知是女性。当把这个人呈现为一位非常强势且非常有野心的人时，我们发现，如果是女性，人们会觉得她比身为男性时更加不讨人喜欢。需要明确的是，这位强势的男女经理在描述上完全相同，甚至精确到每一个字母。唯一的不同是，一个被设定为男性，另一个被设定为女性。玛德琳还研究了会发生什么
when someone joins a company, but is not set to be in a position of power. If we didn't give information about how successful the person was, just had them applying for a job, we find that the women are as likable as the man, but their scene is less competent. And that is the rock in the hard place, the double-bine, that if it's not clear that you're successful and you have the same information about a woman and a man, the woman is seen
当某人加入公司，但并未被设定处于权力位置时。如果我们不提供关于这个人有多成功的信息，只是让他们申请工作，我们发现女性和男性一样讨人喜欢，但她们被认为能力较差。这就是进退维谷的境地，即双重约束：如果并不清楚你是否成功，并且你对女性和男性掌握相同的信息，那么女性就会被视为
as less competent. If you have very clear indication that there is success, then the woman is rated as unlikable. They see her as competent but unlikable. Madeline says the double binderizes because our minds are trying to align our stereotypes about men and women with our stereotypes about leadership. We have conceptions of these jobs and these positions and what is required to do them well and there is a lack of fit between how we see women and what these positions require. The biases Madeline describes aren't just held by men.
能力较差。如果你有非常明确的成功迹象，那么女性就会被评为不讨人喜欢。人们认为她有能力但不讨人喜欢。玛德琳说，双重约束之所以出现，是因为我们的大脑试图将我们对男女的刻板印象与我们对领导力的刻板印象结合起来。我们对这些工作和职位以及做好这些工作所需要的东西有着特定的概念，而在我们如何看待女性与这些职位实际要求之间存在着一种不匹配。玛德琳所描述的偏见不仅存在于男性之中。
They are held by both sexes, which explains why many female leaders encountered derision and suspicion from both men and women. I think that this comes from the social roles that people have played over time. Women stayed home and they took care, men went out, and they took charge of things. That is the kind of origin, I think, of the stereotypes that we hold. We have very strong feelings about how men and women are, and that leads to the idea that women are less competent than men and a lot of these fields that we're talking about. And we have real strong ideas about how
这两种性别都有这种偏见，这就解释了为什么许多女性领导者会遭到男性和女性的嘲笑和怀疑。我认为这源于人们随着时间推移所扮演的社会角色。女性留在家中照顾家庭，男性外出掌管事务。我认为，这就是我们持有的刻板印象的起源。我们对男性和女性应该是什么样有着非常强烈的看法，这导致了一种观念，即在我们要讨论的很多领域中，女性的能力不如男性。而且我们对他们应该如何
they should be, and that leads to this dislike when they go over the line, when they tread where they're not supposed to be. There are other aspects to the double-bind. Female leaders can get in trouble for displaying emotion, but also for not displaying emotion. Lisa Feldman Barrett is a psychology professor at Northeastern University and author of the book How Emotions Are Made. There is an implication that if a woman expresses emotion that she's either unsuitable for leadership are made. In one experiment, Lisa showed volunteers pictures of faces
行事有着非常强烈的看法，当他们越界时，当他们涉足不该涉足的领域时，就会引发这种厌恶。双重约束还有其他方面。女性领导者不仅因为表现出情绪而陷入麻烦，也因为没有表现出情绪而陷入麻烦。莉萨·费尔德曼·巴雷特 (Lisa Feldman Barrett) 是东北大学的心理学教授，也是《情绪是如何产生的》(How Emotions Are Made) 一书的作者。这里有一种暗示，如果女性表达情绪，说明她要么不适合领导地位或制造麻烦。在一个实验中，莉萨向志愿者展示了面孔图片
and asked why the subject was expressing an emotion. She found that the volunteers thought men's emotions were shaped by what was going on around them, but that women's emotions were shaped by their nature. Both men and women, when they were looking at female faces expressing emotion, believed that this was caused by a woman's emotional nature. She's just a neurotic person.
并询问为什么主体在表达情绪。她发现志愿者认为男性的情绪是由他们周围发生的事情决定的，而女性的情绪是由她们的本性决定的。无论男女，当他们看着女性面孔表达情绪时，都认为这是由女性的情绪本性引起的。她只是一个神经过敏的人。
She's just unstable. She's just untrustworthy, as opposed to when they were looking at male faces expressing emotion, they were more likely to say, oh, he's just having a bad day, something bad happened to him. Lots of people have suggested ways out of the double bind. Some say women should ignore criticisms about incompetence and plunge full steam ahead. If they then appear unlikable, they should also go out of their way to demonstrate kindness
她只是不稳定。她只是不可信，而相比之下，当他们看着男性面孔表达情绪时，他们更有可能说，哦，他只是今天过得不好，发生了不好的事情。许多人提出了摆脱双重约束的方法。有些人说女性应该忽视对能力不足的批评，全力以赴地向前推进。如果她们随后显得不讨人喜欢，她们也应该竭尽全力表现出善良
in order to keep people from seeing them as competent but cold. There is something disturbing about these ideas. They ask women who are the victims here to compensate for the biases of others. Many experts also think that a society changes, our stereotypes will change as well. If more women make it through the labyrinth and get to the top, fewer people will have trouble seeing women as leaders. Many countries and organizations are coming to think of leadership as being collaborative rather than dictatorial.
以防止人们认为她们有能力但冷酷。这些想法中有一些令人不安的地方。它们要求作为受害者的女性去弥补他人的偏见。许多专家还认为，随着社会的发展，我们的刻板印象也会改变。如果有更多的女性穿过迷宫并登上顶峰，就会有更少的人难以将女性视为领导者。许多国家和组织开始将领导力视为协作式而非独裁式的。
The less we think of leaders as alpha males, the easier it's going to be for our unconscious minds to see women as leaders. If there's one common thread here, it's that ending the double-bind can't be just on the women reaching for high office or the corner office. It has to be on all of us. This week's episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Jenny Schmitt and edited by Tara Boyle. Our staff also includes Maggie Pennman and Renee Clarre. If you like this episode, I'm going to ask that you tell two friends, one man and one woman, about the show.
我们越少将领导者视为阿尔法男性，我们的无意识大脑就越容易将女性视为领导者。如果这里有一个共同的主题，那就是打破双重约束不能仅仅依靠追求高位或高管办公室的女性。它必须依靠我们所有人。本周的《隐藏的大脑》由珍妮·施密特 (Jenny Schmitt) 制作，塔拉·博伊尔 (Tara Boyle) 编辑。我们的员工还包括玛吉·佩恩曼 (Maggie Pennman) 和雷妮·克拉尔 (Renee Klahr)。如果你喜欢这集节目，我想请你把这个节目告诉两个朋友，一个男的，一个女的。
Our unsung hero this week is Anja Grunman. She's the person who oversees NPR's podcasts. She's always had our back, and there's a reason her calendar is always maxed out. Anja is the very definition of that collaborative leader we were just talking about. She makes everyone around her better. Today we're also honoring the work of another remarkable colleague, producer Chris Benderev, who's been with us at Hidden Brain for a few months. He's about to return to his role on NPR's Embedded Podcast.
我们本周的无名英雄是安娅·格伦曼 (Anja Grunman)。她是负责监督 NPR 播客的人。她一直支持我们，她的日程表总是满满当当的，这是有原因的。安娅正是我们刚才谈到的那种协作型领导者的完美定义。她让周围的每个人都变得更好。今天我们还要表彰另一位杰出的同事——制作人克里斯·班德雷夫 (Chris Benderev) 的工作，他在过去的几个月里一直和我们一起在《隐藏的大脑》工作。他即将回到他在 NPR 的《嵌入式播客》(Embedded Podcast) 中的角色。
Chris has graded everything he does, which would be a little obnoxious if you weren't also one of the nicest people we know. Thank you Chris, for all the great work you've done on this show. You can find more Hidden Brain on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Veta Antham and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
克里斯对他的每一项工作都精益求精，如果你不是我们认识的最友善的人之一，这其实会有点招人讨厌。谢谢你，克里斯，感谢你为这个节目所做的一切出色工作。你可以在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上找到更多《隐藏的大脑》，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。我是尚卡尔·维塔坦姆 (Shankar Vedantam)，这是 NPR。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。